Olá a todos, e bem-vindo de volta
ao
FP101x - Functional Programming.
O que vamos
fazer hoje é dar os primeiros
passos no aprendizado de Haskell.
Um dos meus filmes favoritos de todos
os tempos
é o Karate Kid e se você não viu
este filme,
pare de assistir
esta aula e vá assistir ao filme
primeiro.
Sempre que preciso aprender algo novo,
eu assisto Karate Kid novamente
e posso dizer à vocês... eu vi
talvez
20 ou 30 vezes e sempre que assisto,
aprendo algo novo.
Se você
assistir o filme, verá que
o garoto aqui, Daniel, quer
aprender caratê
e o senhor Miyagi, o cavalheiro
aqui
do outro lador, faz ele fazer um
monte de
exercícios que o Daniel acha que
são inúteis. E ele fica meio frustrado.
Mas afim de aprender algo você tem
que ir
através de uma série de exercícios, porque há
uma grande quantidade de memória muscular ou,
no caso de programação você deve ter a
memória muscular em seus dedos.
São coisas que você não deveria ter que
pensar.
Você tem que insistir. Você tem que
fazer uma e outra e outra vez.
E isso é o que vamos fazer na
aula de hoje.
Então, não fique frustrado.
Não seja como o Daniel.
Fique de castigo e apenas faça seus
exercícios: wax on wax off, wax on, wax off...
(praticar, praticar e praticar)
até que que se torne completamente
automático
e então você pode usar seu cérebro para
resolver o problema real.
Você não tem mais que pensar nos conceitos
básicos. E toda vez que você aprender
algo novo
assista este grande filme.
Vamos mostrar um pouco de Haskell.
A implementação Haskell que vamos usar
neste curso é a Glasgow Haskell
Compiler
as vezes também chamada de Glorious
Haskell Compiler
e GHC é a principal implementação de
Haskell.
Ela tem tanto o compilador quanto
um REPL loop
interativo que você pode usar para
digitar o seu
código.
A natureza interativa
do interpretador GHC deixa
realmente fácil
de experimentar com Haskell
e este é o motivo pelo qual é também
muito útil para este curso.
Muitos dos exercícios
que vocês terão durante o curso,
vocês podem fazer
usando o GHC.
Eu não
vejo isso como trapacear pois
como programadores, devemos realmente usar
o compilador
para nos ajudar. O computador está lá
para nos ajudar a programar o computador.
Se não o usarmos, seria estúpido.
GHC
está gratuitamente disponível no website
aqui. O link estará também no
website do curso, e vocês podem também
usar o Google ou Bing para buscar
sobre a plataform Haskell
que está disponível para as principais
plafatormas
Mac, Windows e Linux.
Para iniciar o GHC,
apenas digite a linha de comando 'ghci'
e então vocês terão um
texto surgindo e verão um prompt
Prelude> e que é onde vocês podem
começar a digitar
expressões. Por exemplo, podemos digitar
a expressão
2 + 3 * 4 e
o GHCI imprimirá então o resultado da expressão.
Neste caso estamos realmente usando
o GHCi como um tipo de calculadora.
É como uma pequena calculadora
na interface de linha de comando,
em vez de uma calculdora com botões.
O que vemos também é que desde que
2 + 3 * 4 é aparentemente 14
a multiplicação é mais forte do que
a adição. Assim, não há surpresas
aqui pois
a maioria das linguagens tem isso.
Se queremos
fazer a adição primeiro e depois
a multiplicação, temos que colocar
parêntesis, assim escrevemos
(2 + 3) * 4
e então o resultado é 20.
Podemos fazer
expressões mais complicadas como a
raiz quadrada de (3 ^ 2 + 4 ^2)
e obtemos 5.
Como vocês viram, existe o
Prelude>
prompt
aqui. Assim, o Haskell Prelude é como
o SDK para Haskell. Estas são todas as
funções padrão
que vem de graça com Haskell.
No website
falaremos à vocês como obter
outras bibliotecas para Haskell,
mas não iremos discutir isso em muitos
detalhes aqui. Vocês
podem examinar isso.
Tentaremos
ficar apenas com as funções da
biblioteca padrão - o prelude
padrão.
Muitas das funões no prelude
são funções de listas.
Vamos passar por algumas
delas e então mais tarde no curso
implementaremos estas funções
de várias maneiras
diferentes. A primeira função aqui é a head,
que recebe uma lista,
a forma de escrevermos uma lista em Haskell
é com colchetes e os
elementos separados por vírgula,
então a head de [1,2,3,4,5] é
sem dúvida 1.
O tail,
o oposto de head, é
tudo na lista
exceto o head, então o tail de [1,2,3,4,5]
é a lista [2,3,4,5].
Podemos também selecionar
o n-th elemento de uma lista com
este operador
de dois pontos de exclamações.
Se queremos selecionar o segundo elemento
da lista
[1,2,3,4,5] obtemos
3. Então, o que aprendemos disto?
Bem...
que o primeiro elemento da lista
tem índice 0.
Haskell inicia
o índice da lista por zero.
Há
2 pontos de exclamação aqui e há
uma grande razão para isso:
porque em Haskell,
listas não são arrays,
então a indexação de
uma lista aqui no segundo elemento
atravessará a lista. Então, ela
atravessará a lista, joga fora 1
jogar 1 2 e então retorna 3.
Isto não é uma operação
com tempo constante. Indexação em uma lista,
ao contrário da indexação em uma array,
em Haskell é linear no comprimento
da lista.
Em geral linear no tamando da
lista.
Mas felizmente
dificilmente veremos uso
deste operador na prática.
Se vocês se acharem querendo usar
indexação de lista
então vocês sabem que não fizeram
wax on, wax off, wax on, wax off suficiente.
Você ainda está muito na mentalidade da
programação imperativa usando arrays.
Em Haskell nós tipicamente usamos higher
order functions como map, filter, fold
e não indexação para
executar operações complexas em listas.
Aqui outro
exemplo - take 3 - ele pega os três primeiros
elementos de uma lista. Se temos
a lista [1,2,3,4,5]
ele retorna os três primeiros
elementos.
[1,2,3]
Drop
é o oposto, ele pega um número
e a lista e ele remove os primeiros
três elementos da lista. De alguma
forma, drop
e take são
generalizações de head e tail.
Head e tail
apenas pegam o primeiro e o resto de uma
lista e então com take e drop
vocês podem generalizar para
números arbitrários.
Calculando o comprimento de uma lista...
o que fazemos
chamando a função length.
Length de [1,2,3,4,5] is 5.
Novamente, listas em Haskell não são
como arrays
em outras linguagens, pegar o comprimento
não é uma operação de tempo constante.
Leva tempo linearmente no
comprimento de uma lista.
Sum soma todos os elementos
se chamamos sum de [1,2,3,4,5]
o resultado é 15.
Product
é o mesmo que sum, exceto que em vez
de adicionar os números, ela
multiplica todos eles, então
multiplicando
1, 2, 3, 4 e 5 - como obter
o fatorial de 5 -
é 120. Juntar duas listas é outra
operação comum: vocẽ pega duas listas e
esmagam elas juntas em outra lista nova,
então se eu faço
append [1,2,3] com [4,5]
temos a lista [1,2,3,4,5].
A última função aqui
neste slide é inverter  uma lista.
Reverse [1,2,3,4,5] dá a você
[5,4,3,2,1]
No resto
desta aula, nós definiremos todas
estas funções nós mesmos
de diversas formas, mas agora
é bom brincar com elas para ver
o que fazem,
e então estaremos prontos
para implementa-lás.
Then we will know what they are
supposed to do.
Here's
another very important slide
and that is about function application.
Haskell
is very different than mathematics on
the one side
and very different from other
programming languages as well.
In mathematics when you apply a function -
mathematics that you do in school or
college when you take analysis -
when you apply a function to an argument,
you always use parentheses.
In this case
when we apply a function here...
this is
applying a function f to arguments
a and b
and then adding c
space d.
In mathematics,
typically, and that comes from
physics
is that space means multiplication.
If you look at the mathematical
textbook
and you see c d
it usually means c multiplied by d
and therefore when you apply a function
you're using
parentheses like this to disambiguate.
Since in Haskell
function application is used much more
often
than multiplication,
whereas in physics
multiplication is used more often, so
that's where
multiplication is given the most
white symbol, the least
visible symbol, the most white spacey symbol.
In Haskell,
function application is denoted by white
space
so that it's not so much in
your face.
So in Haskell instead of writing
f (a,b) + c d
function application
becomes
denoted by a space,
so it's f a b + c * d
In most programming languages
you would write
f (a, b) so they are in
some sense the
worst of two worlds: there you
have to write everything explicit.
In Haskell we made the decision that
function application
is done by using a space and
multiplication
is done by using multiplication.
Also,
function application binds stronger
than any other operator.
If you see
f a + b, that means
f applied to a
plus b,
It doesn't mean f
applied to (a + b).
People have to get used to this.
This doesn't mean
f times a plus b.
It means
f applied
to a plus b.
So that's
kind of similar to multiplication binding
stronger than addition.
Here's a table that give you
a couple of more expressions
on the one side Haskell,
and on the other side mathematics.
So this is what you should forget.
I'm going to stand in front of that..this
is what you should forget.
And this is what you should learn.
So forget what's behind me and learn
what's on this side.
Instead of f open parentheses x,
we write
f space x. Instead of passing two
parameters to f
we apply f to x and then
apply that result to y.
Instead of f open parens g, open parens x
we can write
f of g of x and later we'll see
that we can write that using function
composition
as f composed g.
the rest of the examples
should be obvious.
If you just look at
shapes of these two - don't try to
interpret them - you will see that the
Haskell code here
looks much lighter-weight than the code
on this side. Haskell programmers are
lazy - we don't want to type too much -
so this looks much more beautiful
than this
and that's why Haskell's syntax is designed
the way it is.
Thank you!.
This was the end of Part 1.
See you in a bit for the remainder of
chapter 1.